this is the 15th anniversary of james
brown's death the funkiest man on the
planet the man who invented funk by me
who funked everything up gary got to
play trumpet for james brown james brown
one of his many uh studio visits
whenever james brown wanted to come in i
had him in because i love james brown
and so gary like ruins james brown's
song you know what i love about it
james brown was known to be a stickler
about his band being perfect yeah he
would fire dudes oh yeah and he could
hear
anything that was off or off time so
when gary was playing for him that's all
i could think of that he has to endure
[Music]
papa's got a brand new bag
[Music]
so after the song james brown went out
in the hall with gary and he said um
listen uh let me give you some advice on
how to be a better trumpet player he put
his arm around me he walked me over to
the side and he said and i remember it
was something like to the effect of like
here's what's going on you are playing
on the upbeat and you need to be playing
on the downbeat as if i know what any of
that means
but it was very sweet it really was i'm
working on getting better but don't
worry about playing the melody okay
don't play the matter
i didn't know you were playing anything
here's what's going on you're terrible
and you're fired from the band but mr
brown i'm not in the band you got to do
it on the downbeat not the upbeat gary's
like what's a beat yeah like which one
is that
i would have been like here's what you
got to do throw out that trumpet pick up
another instrument break it down never
ever play from smash it over your mouth
in honor of james brown i would now like
to present you with a little song we put
together using gary's phlegm it's called
the flemmi drummer here it is
[Music]
[Music]
yes